this is the red knee tarantula she's got  quite the outfit  unfortunately her striking features have  made her a hot commodity in the illegal  pet trade found in the forests of  southwestern Mexico red deeds are some  of the largest spiders growing up to  eight inches in size besides size their  beautiful red white black and orange has  are what separates them from other  spiders the hairs on their legs are used  to sense vibrations from predators and  prey they prey on large insects frogs  and mice biting and injecting them with  their venom their alluring look has made  them the most popular captive tarantula  causing a major population to climb  today regulations are in place requiring  permits to remove any of these beauties  from the wild this is the red knee  tarantula